what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
over the past few days we have been
treated to
a lot of spider-man no way home leaks
and then immediately following up the
leaks on the same day we got the
official releases from
marvel hasbro funko and lego now we have
all of this but we have
not gotten the trailer yet which i
actually think is a pretty good
tactic used by sony and marvel right now
releasing all of this stuff
to kind of give us a little bit of info
about the movie to get off their backs
just a little bit because i do fully
believe that all of this
was planned i definitely think it was a
marketing tactic
which is smart but the purpose of
today's video is to address something
that a lot of people have been asking me
about because if you noticed in all of
these leaks we saw
nothing for any other spider-man but tom
hollins
no signs of tobey maguire no signs of
andrew garfield
and really we didn't get any signs of
any other character that we really
haven't seen before
however that does not mean that toby and
andrew aren't going to be in the film
and it looks like they are actually
going to be getting funko pops
themselves
of their own spider-man so don't think
that just because we haven't seen
any leaks of their funkos or lego sets
that they're not in the movie and in
this video i'll explain some missing
pieces of the puzzle
and of course if you love spider-man and
want to stay up to date on the mcu be
sure to subscribe and hit the
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any videos
so yesterday six funko pops were
revealed for spider-man no way home
three different versions of spider-man
and then ned doctor strange and
mj and some people were thinking that
these three different versions of
spider-man could be the three different
spider-man but
they are all tom holland however if you
look closely you start to notice
something
the numbers aren't in order and we're
actually missing
several numbers if you notice we have
913
921 923 925
912 and 924 those numbers don't line up
in numerical order which means there is
a huge gap
in what they've chosen to release here
and what hasn't been released yet
you see here we're missing eight funkos
that they chose not to reveal
914 915 16 9 17 9
18 9 19 9 20 and 9 22
and these missing funkos that they have
not revealed yet are most likely for the
other characters that marvel and sony
are choosing not to reveal
because again i do believe that marvel
and sony did this intentionally right
after the leaks came out they were
actually on their websites
officially posted so it seems like they
were very intentional on
what leaks got out and you notice that
there aren't really any leaks that give
us any clue towards the spider-verse but
the missing funkos that have not been
revealed yet
are most likely for those other
characters that are coming from other
universes
these will be funko pops for characters
like tobey maguire spider-man
andrew garfield spider-man doc ock who
of course is confirmed for the movie as
well as elektra who was confirmed as
well
and then the others are probably going
to be the other villains such as the
green goblin sandman
and all of the other ones rumored to
appear in the movie now they may not all
be in reference to spider-man no way
home for example they just revealed a
hawkeye one and it is 9 14. so that's
one of the missing pieces but with so
many characters coming in spider-man no
way home we could probably assume that
at least
half of these missing numbers are
characters related to spider-man no way
home and we could probably safely assume
that two of them are going to be toby
maguire spider-man and andrew garfield
spider-man
because there's absolutely no way that
marvel and sony are going to do a
spider-verse film
and not sell funkos for the other
spider-man in fact they're probably
going to sell out of these funkos pretty
quickly so if you are a funko pop fan be
sure to get these
right when they come out and keep in
mind that some of these are walmart and
target exclusive
but a lot of people were saying that
because they didn't show any leaks of
tobey maguire and andrew garfield that
means that they're not going to actually
be in the film
and that is definitely not the case
there are clearly tons of funko pops
missing here that they have chosen not
to show us
and i really do believe that they're
going to wait till the final
final moment to actually reveal toby
maguire and andrew garfield
i'm still not even sure if they'll show
it in the trailer yet but we'll have to
wait and see on that
in the meantime let me know what you
think about this these missing funkos in
the comments down below don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter i usually post a
lot of things on there first before
doing videos
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof